we've had this continued discussion
about why Donald Trump won't release his
taxes the speculation has been pretty
straight forward there's gotta be
something really bad in there either
Donald Trump is not nearly as rich as he
claims to be and that would be damaging
in terms of the optics as the ten
billionaire duh-uh a candidate he maybe
has not donated as much to charity as he
claims to have donated maybe he has not
been paying federal taxes as we know at
least during some years decades ago he
didn't do he may have ties to Russia
Hillary Clinton did a pretty good job in
that first debate earlier this week in
pointing out some of these possibilities
there's something really really
interesting though that we've now
learned which is Donald Trump is not
always against releasing tax returns the
associated press the AP has pointed out
the Donald Trump in the past when there
was profit to be made through some
casino dealings did actually release his
tax returns pennsylvania gaming
regulators were given at least five
years worth and eight boxes full of
Donald Trump tax documents Nevada
Michigan Missouri and Indiana had access
to multiple years of Donald Trump tax
returns and there were also large banks
which loaned money to Donald Trump which
over the years received Donald Trump's
tax returns he had to do that in order
to do business in their states now all
we're trying to do is see if it's okay
for Trump to be the most powerful person
in the world pales in comparison to
building a casino in Michigan doesn't it
no not really uh what is abundantly
clear here and I have felt this for the
entire race Donald Trump probably never
wanted to and probably still doesn't
really want to be President of the
United States and this pushes me in that
same direction if you don't release your
tax returns in accordance with modern
presidential custom for 40 years knowing
that it is causing your campaign damage
knowing that a majority of Americans
want to see those tax returns many polls
have told us this if you still choose
not to release the tax returns then but
you release them to inquire about doing
casino business in Michigan or
Pennsylvania or whatever States it was
that to me says you care way more about
the possibility of a casino in Michigan
than you do about being president of the
United States and the the read the
conclusion that I have to draw from from
this is that it is more important to
Donald Trump to protect whatever is in
those tax returns to protect business
interests that are related to past
releases of tax returns that it is to be
upfront and open and honest with the
American people there must be something
really damaging in those tax returns uh
I I can't think of anything else that
would make someone take this position
there's the story Howard Stern the radio
host once ran for governor of New York
as a libertarian and I believe he
actually was formally nominated as the
libertarian candidate at the Libertarian
Party convention of New York there
there's more details to the story I'm
sure you can look it up and he really
wasn't doing badly he could have at
least stood a shot at becoming governor
of New York it was gonna be an easy race
but he had a shot and at a certain point
he was told well okay now you have to
release your personal finances your
taxes in your personal finances and he
said I don't want this badly enough and
I'm not doing that and I've no interest
in making my financial dealings public
this sort of started as a goof although
I think maybe I could win and I think to
this day he still says he could have won
uh I'm a radio host in the end and I'm
not releasing my tax returns and he was
super upfront about it and whether it
was about something damaging or not
we'll never know it probably would have
revealed that he was a very very wealthy
man which we now know that he is what
about Donald Trump who has gotten way
further right this was Howard Stern
being in a early in a gubernatorial race
a third party nominee Donald Trump is
polling close to fifty percent after
becoming the Republican nominee for the
presidency of the United States
and he's still not willing to release
those tax returns big picture trumps
casinos are more important to him than
being president that should concern
voters it certainly concerns me